welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity the left has a track record of
bowing to dictators but President Trump
maintains of peace through strength
policy and that was on full display this
morning Trump tweeted quote I have asked
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo not to go
to North Korea at this time because I
feel we are not making sufficient
progress with respect to the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
additionally because of our much tougher
trading stance with China I do not
believe they are helping with the
process of denuclearization as they were
once were despite the UN sanctions which
are in place Secretary of Pompeo looks
forward to going to North Korea in the
near future most likely after our
trading relationship with China is
resolved in the meantime I would like to
send my warmest regards and respect to
Chairman came I look forward to seeing
him soon joining us now with reaction
national security and global affairs
analyst morgan ortega and fox news
contributor and retired CIA senior
intelligence officer Dan Hoffman okay
Morgan I'll start with you yesterday
Mike Pompeo is going to North Korea
along with a special envoy indicating
that we're ready to continue serious
negotiations with the North Korea now
today something very unusual happened
when the president asked Secretary of
State Pompeo nights ago what happened
and how do you read this well good good
evening judge nanine great to see you as
always
I think what we're seeing happen is that
Mike Pompeo the secretary state briefed
the president today and it seems that
the president got fed up and was
frustrated with what he sees as a lack
of progress on these talks and the
president we saw did this in the lead-up
to the Singapore talks where he canceled
the meeting with Kim jong-un and then
the North Koreans came back to the table
in a way that was sufficient from the
president's perspective and to the
meeting went forward so I think what
we're really seeing here is so many
different geopolitical things at play
Janene we're seeing the trade talks
happened with the Chinese which I think
are be are very tough they did not seem
to make a lot of progress over the past
few days the Chinese are playing
hardball but so is this president more
than any other president has we're also
seeing something a very strange dynamic
that I think that we need to be aware of
and that's the South Koreans and
president moon is the for lack of a
better word II mean he's the he's the
Barack Obama of Asia and I think that we
have to be very careful about what the
South Koreans are doing they made some
speeches last week last week in which
they're trying to build this this inter
Korean Peninsula almost similar to a
European Union in Asia they want that
land bridge to China into the rest of
Asia so I'm worried that the South
Korean president and his very liberal
stances trying to push a position that
is counter to US interests in the region
dan how do you see what's going on in in
North Korea with Kim jong-un in his own
country what are the dynamics that are
going on there well you know first of
all we've submitted proposals for a
pathway and a timeline for
denuclearization and thus far Kim
jong-un has resisted those he's trying
to exact maximum economic gain without
giving up the nuclear arsenal on which
his regimes security depends and that
really does reflect the fact that his
economy is in freefall he needs
immediate help and he has to play to his
own stakeholders in the military you may
recall that just before the summit Kim
jong-un removed three top defense
officials including his chief of
intelligence and his Minister of Defense
he's got to be very concerned and aware
of the reaction from his own for lack of
a better word military base
he's been ruthless about suppressing his
own people and ruthless about killing
those who get in his way including his
half-brother in Malaysia well you know
but if Kim Jong I'm gonna stay with you
Dan for a minute if he's in a free fall
and the economy how does he juggle all
of this it's a delicate balancing act
but he's getting a lot of help right now
from China as well as from Russia and
that is I agree with the president
that's the real challenge for us is we
need to
step up those sanctions I think it might
be a time for us to consider
reinstituting those military exercises
just to put a little bit more pressure
on Kim jong-un but also on China and
Russia and show them that we're serious
okay it's so Morgan I'm gonna go back to
you on what what you opened up with a
couple of minutes ago and that is the
interaction with China I mean how do we
juggle that it's an incredibly complex
issue but I think that the way President
Trump is countering China is the single
most important thing that from a foreign
policy perspective that he will do in
his presidency judge seeing we have not
had the stomach to do what it takes to
counter China and we tend to look at
North Korea and China we look at trade
we look at sanctions we look at these
issues in silos and I think what's
really smart about what this
administration is doing and a lot of
people would disagree with me on this
but I think the fact that we are looking
at the Chinese looking at the theft of
IP looking at sanctions on North Korea
and trying to negotiate with them in a
package I think is a smart strategy but
mind you this is not something that's
going to happen that he's that the
president Trump is going to win in the
next month or maybe even the next year
this is something where we have to have
sustained pressure against the Chinese
because most of the world thinks that
when the going gets tough that America
cuts in round that's certainly our
reputation for the last eight years look
what happened in the Middle East look
what would Russia invaded Ukraine and
President Obama did nothing our
reputation is that when it gets tough we
leave and people don't believe that the
President Trump is necessarily going to
keep the required pressure on China and
on North Korea I believe he will I
believe this is a president who means
what he says and I think that the
Chinese and the North Koreans are wrong
to test him and and Dan what do you
think the long-term game long-term game
plan should be with respect to North
Korea and China by the United States
well I think Morgan's points are spot-on
the North Korea challenge for us is
intertwined with everything else in the
region there's no question that China
and Russia would like to reduce if not
eliminate altogether our military
presence and our influence in the region
and so we do need to demonstrate we're
in it for the long haul we also have to
have realistic expectations one more
point judge that I would highlight
when the president was making this
decision he had Andy Kim in the room
Andy is the chief of the CIA's Korea
mission center along with Secretary of
Pompeo this shows the president making a
very deliberate decision based on
intelligence and and the best diplomatic
advice he could get from Secretary
Pompeo and I think we should be
reassured by that process which was spot
on all right and just a few SEC's
seconds left Morgan what about you know
the satellite imagery that seems to
indicate that they are still working on
that North Korea is still working on its
nuclear is a ssin don't they know we
could see that stuff if you would think
they would know that by now for sure and
we also saw that secretary Pompeo went
to the UN just a few weeks ago and said
and called out the Russians and called
out the Chinese for the ship to ship oil
transfers in which they were evading
sanctions so I think that the president
might need to consider going back to the
maximum pressure campaign I think
clearly from his tweets today that he's
still trying to keep a relationship with
Kim jong-un because from this
perspective Kim jong-un promised
denuclearization but might be time to go
back to maximum pressure clearly all
right a great discussion thank you guys